le but de l'espoir à la 58e minute
plaisir vire en tête d'un match serré
mais à l'image de la rencontre les
plaisirs wa n'ont jamais trouvé la
solution face au club 2 ou le vésinet
carrière m 7 buts ou vivus cran en
imitant c'est pas assez pourtant on
défend bien et je pense que le souci qui
a été réglé en deuxième c'est qu'on a
acquis peu à des balcons a couru on n'a
pas couru en première on n'a pas joué
les montées de balle et c'est ça devrait
être d'autres points forts savez si on
ne fait pas ça marchera
[Musique]
un match qui devait se tenir le 27
septembre dernier reportée après des cas
contactez la rencontre est maintenant
synonyme d'une première victoire dans le
championnat pour le hbc le club débute
sa première saison en nationale 3
l'attitude des joueurs la mentalité on
avait on avait à coeur de commencer le
championnat on avait à coeur de faire
une bonne prestation on était un peu
stressé ça se voyait sur le terrain
c'était pas fluide on est et on était
tendue mais de la solidarité et la
défense surtout va à 21,20 c'était un
match de défense
nos gardiens ont fait le taff et notre
défense a fait le taf
prochain match pour les plaisirs ou à
face à bois colombes où il affrontait le
club de puteaux rendez vous pour les
deux matches le samedi 7 novembre